[Music]  [Applause]  i say either  yeah either i say neither  can i say neither either  neither neither let's call the whole  thing off  catch up excuse me  yummy  good evening eddie hey mrs chen good  evening venom  mrs chen he says hi one  is the loneliest number that you'll ever  do i've been thinking about yeah  you and i are the same  every decision we ever make  [Music]  who do we leave behind  and how do we leave them  waiting in the darkness of the rescuer  who never comes  [Applause]  welcome back eddie brock it's been a  long time  miss you so much  [Applause]  soon come chaos  chaos soon come on  the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived  yet no we had a deal  what's gonna happen you're gonna stop  protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen  no no you cannot eat mrs chen what  nothing  [Music]  you